was nun frau berbalk russland führt nun
einen angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
hat heute abend womöglich schon die
außenbezirke von kiew erreicht und ist
dabei das ganze land zu erobern dort an
zu marschieren aus ihrer sicht gibt es
noch einen weg putin zu stoppen
das was in diesen stunden minuten
passiert ist macht ein fassungslos macht
seien fassungslos nicht sprachlos
deswegen haben wir heute auch so
deutlich gesagt dass das mit jeglichen
grundlagen nicht nur das völkerrecht
sondern des menschlichen zusammenlebens
bericht und wir tun jetzt alles dafür
menschen in sicherheit zu bringen
deutsche staatsangehörige aber natürlich
auch die menschen die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer die jetzt über die polnische
grenze kommen und vor diesen angriffen
fliehen
der westen wird heute noch weitere
sanktionen auch verhängen das ist
jedenfalls ziel auch eines gipfels aber
davon lässt putin sich ja offenbar nicht
beeindrucken jedenfalls haben die
drohungen der letzten tage und wochen
ihn ja nicht aufhalten können deshalb
noch mal die frage welchen weg gibt es
noch ihn zu stoppen oder können wir am
ende im moment nur noch zusehen wie die
ukraine sich einverleibt in diesen
minuten so furchtbar das ist erleben wir
wie stück für stück die truppen
russische truppen vor marschieren wir
erleben aber auch dass es widerstand von
seiten der ukraine gibt da sie
angesprochen haben das hat ja
offensichtlich in den letzten tagen
nicht so mit diplomatischen beziehungen
funktioniert muss man sich glaube ich
noch mal vergegenwärtigen was für eine
rede der russische präsident gehalten
hat also da war nichts von einem handeln
was unseren grundlagen von rationaler
politischer verantwortung entspricht
sondern vollkommen entgrenzte
agieren wenn man einem anderen land was
ja eigentlich so eng auch kulturell mit
familiären beziehungen miteinander
verbunden ist das existenzrecht
abspricht dann macht das deutlich dass
er gewillt ist offensichtlich mit allen
mitteln und zwar mit allen mitteln
selbst wenn das der bruch mit allen
nicht nur politischen völkerrechtlichen
sondern menschlich regeln ist diesen
vormarsch jetzt voranzutreiben sollen
sie frau berbalk er ist nicht zu stoppen
wenn man sich mal die rede anguckt nicht
mehr die vor zwei tagen sondern auch die
von heute nacht dann hat er ja nicht nur
den angriff auf die ukraine befohlen mit
dieser rede und begonnen sondern
gleichzeitig den westen uns vor
konsequenzen gewarnt zitat konsequenzen
wie sie europa noch nicht gesehen hat
und er sagte wörtlich wir sind zu allem
bereit wie verstehen sie das bauwerk ist
das eine unverhohlene drohung von putin
selbst mit atomwaffen und auch gegen uns
erstmal ist als menschenverachtend muss
man sagen wenn man mit allen bereit ist
das menschenleben von jeglichen kindern
frauen und männern aufs spiel zu setzen
um seine wahnvorstellungen durchzusetzen
dann ist es menschenverachtend und auf
der anderen seite macht das so deutlich
es geht eben nicht nur um die ukraine
das haben sie ja auch mit angesprochen
es geht um die europäische
friedensordnung es geht aber auch um die
politische auseinandersetzung und die
wird weitergehen und deswegen ist es
auch so wichtig dass wir jetzt
geschlossen sagen wir akzeptieren das
nicht als weltgemeinschaft nicht nur als
europäerinnen und europäer welche steht
ja nicht nur russland was die ukraine
angreift sondern hier steht ein
verständnis freie liberale demokratien
und auf der anderen seite ein
autoritäres regime dem offensichtlich
jegliche mittel recht sind um seine
macht vorstellungen durchzusetzen diese
freie liberale demokratien das müssen
wir verteidigen wir müssen das
völkerrecht verteidigen und deutlich
machen das ist die grundlage der
internationalen gemeinschaft und
deswegen bin ich dieser minuten auch
angesichts dieser bilder
mit allem daran deutlich zu machen wir
reagieren darauf mit anderen partnern
mit außenministern weltweit im gespräch
zu sagen ihr müsst euch jetzt euch sein
wir müssen als weltgemeinschaft zeigen
wir nehmen das als welt nicht hin damit
diese auseinandersetzung über das
internationale recht eine klare grenze
erhält wir nehmen das nicht hin sagen
sie jetzt hört man heute allerdings auch
schon viel selbst kritik aus der
deutschen politik auch vizekanzler
harbeck sagt der besten seiten naiv
gewesen
umgang mit putin die frühere
verteidigungsminister in kramp
karrenbauer sie werden das gelesen haben
beklagt dass man eben in den letzten
jahren nicht ausreichend mittel
aufgebaut hätte und putin abzuschrecken
ziehen sie auch den schluss heute abend
das im grunde jetzt die deutsche
russland politik der letzten jahrzehnte
muss man sagen am ende ist weiß ich erst
mal wichtig finde weil auch dass ein
teil dieser großen strategie ist und das
dürfen wir nicht unterschätzen es geht
wie gesagt auch um die große strategie
in der welt eine einnahme tiefe zu
verbreiten dass er sagte ja auch immer
der westen hätte hier
eskaliert nein es ist russland was
allein die verantwortung dafür dafür
trägt und deswegen ist so wichtig die
geschlossenheit weil sie hat gefragt
habe die deutsche die deutsche
verantwortung als europäer haben in der
vergangenheit gehandelt auch mit blick
auf die russland frage das habe ich in
der vergangenheit ja auch deutlich
gemacht zum beispiel in austria 2 dass
wir eben hinter energielieferungen nicht
nur energielieferung sehen sondern die
geostrategische frage jeder hier ist ali
steht aber jetzt zu sagen was es damals
falsch gelaufen ja das müssen wir uns
genau anschauen nur in diesem moment
geht es dafür einzustehen dass wir
verteidigen was unsere internationale
zusammenarbeit ist und das ist das
internationale recht sie haben von
wahnvorstellungen gesprochen bei putin
eben in diesem gespräch und das drehbuch
nachdem er jetzt handelt war doch
vorhersehbar und bekannt dass begann mit
georgien die krim seine
revisionistischen reden hat jeder hören
können aber sie sind doch auch im westen
von denen sie jetzt geschlossenheit
höheren erfordern weitgehend ignoriert
worden deutschland hat doch bis zuletzt
geglaubt durch frieden durch dialog
durch verständigung sozusagen putin
stoppen zu können war das nicht sogar
mehr als naivität war das ein signal der
schwäche dass putin jetzt als einladung
zu dieser aggression verstanden hat
nein offensichtlich war es so dass das
was jetzt passiert ist schon seit
längeren einem skript gefolgt ist und
auf der anderen seite ist der punkt wenn
man vorkommen entgrenzt handelt und auf
der anderen seite wir sind die sagen für
uns gibt es natürlich grenzen dass man
mit einem reinen narrativ dagegen zu
halten wir müssen alles doppelt so hart
machen wird man nicht erfolgreich sein
sondern dann haben wir ein komplett
grenzenloses handeln und deswegen ist
für mich der wichtige punkt diese
internationale geschlossenheit deutlich
zu machen wir isolieren
russland das haben wir in der
vergangenheit um auf ihre frage zu
kommen das haben wir in der
vergangenheit offensichtlich nicht klar
und deutlich genug gesagt ist und auch
eine kritik und ihren vorgängern
anmerken an schulter an der ganzen
deutschen russland politik wissen sie
deswegen ich da jetzt darauf eingehen
will nicht weil ich sage man muss nicht
reflektieren das in der vergangenheit
nicht gut gelaufen ist aber jetzt ist
der absolut falsche moment wo man aus
meiner sicht mit dem finger darauf zeigt
was sie andere regierung gemacht habe
sondern ich finde es jetzt so wichtig
und das erleben wir gerade dass wir
zwischen opposition und regierung ganz
geschlossen stehen und alle die union
alle die im parlament sind deutlich
sagen hier handelt ein land und zwar ein
mann ein staatschef alleine auf kosten
von menschenleben sie haben das
angesprochen mit der krim ich würde es
gerne mal aus gehören weil krieg klingt
so abstrakt aber ich war ja vor einigen
tagen an der kontakt linie und zwar mit
der stellvertretenden
ukrainischen außenministerin mein alter
die hat auch eine tochter sie hat mir
dann der kontakt linie erzählt meine
tochter hat ihre großeltern seit jahren
nicht gesehen weil wir auf der krim
gelebt haben sie wurde vertrieben sie
wurde als persona non grata erklärt das
heißt sie wurde einmal vertrieben und
jetzt steht diese außenministerin mit
ihrer tochter erneut jahre danach vor
der situation dass putin erklärt hat er
will die staatsführung
eliminieren und und das ist jetzt so ein
moment deswegen ich sage ich fange jetzt
nicht an zu sagen was in der
vergangenheit von regierung vorher
falsch gemacht wurden sind natürlich
müssen wir auch reflektieren aber jetzt
müssen wir vor allem dafür sorgen dass
wir den menschen die wir überhaupt noch
schutz geben können wirklich auch schutz
geben und wie gesagt deutlich machen wir
sept ihren diesen massiven bruch des
völkerrechts nicht und sie sind jetzt in
der verantwortung wenn wir da man nach
vorne schauen wenn sie sagen russland
isolieren dann ist es doch jetzt ihre
aufgabe russland eben nicht mehr als
partner nicht mehr auf kooperation zu
setzen sondern als gegner zu sehen kommt
auf sie da auch die aufgabe zu so eine
art gleichgewicht des schreckens
wiederherzustellen
wir haben heute den kanzler gehört nicht
zurück in den kalten krieg aber immerhin
war es doch ein system der
funktionierenden abschreckung sage ich
mal kommt das auf sie zu eine neue
russland ordnung der russland politik
also zum einen weil ihre frage war muss
man jetzt nicht da mal deutlich sagen
russland nicht mehr als partner zu
verschieden das habe ich das hat diese
bundesregierung das haben wir europäer
sehr sehr deutlich in den letzten wochen
und monaten gesagt man muss klar sagen
wir wurden belogen wir haben gesagt wir
haben einen weg der härte und des
dialoges weil das unser verständnis
davon ist von einem friedlichen
miteinander in der nachbarschaft immer
auf dialog zu setzen und ja da muss man
ehrlich sagen wir wurden eiskalt belogen
der kanzler wurde belogen ich bei vom
russischen außenminister die gesamte
internationale gemeinschaft aber das ist
doch dann der punkt wenn man an dem ist
zu sagen weil der eine lügen wir jetzt
auch nein das machen wir nicht wir
stehen zu unseren werten ein und
zugleich sind wir klar und deutlich dass
wir erleben wir müssen auch härte zeigen
deswegen verstärken wir jetzt die
truppen an der nato außengrenze mit
unseren verbündeten deswegen machen wir
deutlich wir werden nicht akzeptieren
dass es zu weiteren massiven
verletzungen des völkerrechts kommt aber
sich auf ein spiel einzulassen von
jemand der sich an keine regeln hält
dann zu sagen wir halten uns auch nicht
mehr an regeln das wäre aus meiner sicht
der falsche weg weil dann hätte putin
gewonnen er will die internationale
ordnung er will das verständnis von
einer staatengemeinschaft die auf regeln
basiert kaputt machen und das ist wie
gesagt der größere teil seines spiels
befreien da brauchen wir nur mehr
geschlossenheit oder brauchen wir nicht
wirklich mehr glaubwürdige militärische
abschreckung und bedeutet das für die
grünen nicht auch in der abkehr von
ihrem bisherigen kurs
da wären eine rückfrage von welchen
bisherigen kurs wir haben klar in den
letzten wochen habe ich ja gerade gesagt
mit blick auf die nato unsere
einsatzfähigkeit auch die schnelle
einsatzfähigkeit
verstärkt wir haben alle vorbereitungen
dafür getroffen
der weg auf der einen seite dialog und
auf der anderen seite hätte ist aus
meiner sicht der richtige weg wir
erleben aber wenn wir die bundeswehr
anschauen zum beispiel dass er mit blick
auf material natürlich deutlich deutlich
mehr machen müssen wenn wir sagen wir
müssen auch unsere soldaten in einsätze
schicken beziehungsweise unsere soldaten
verstärken jetzt im baltikum dann müssen
die natürlich auch so ausgestattet sein
dass die materialien dafür zur verfügung
stehen und dieser diskussion haben ja
schon ein bisschen länger dass wir mit
blick auf die beschaffung in deutschland
definitiv besser werden ist besser
werden müssen der der heeresinspekteur
ist da noch ein bisschen deutlicher
heute er kritisiert sehr scharf die
optionen der bundeswehr seien extrem
limitiert das heer stehe wir zitiert
wird mehr oder weniger blank da wie soll
man da jetzt so schnell reagieren frau
berger die verteilungs pläne für
osteuropa sind aktiviert worden von der
nato unter sind ja auch stehen
erwartungen an deutschland im raum genau
und diese erwartung erfüllen wir jetzt
gemeinsam
man
alles was wir haben stellen wir zur zeit
zur verfügung das hat die
verteidigungsministerin ja auch deutlich
gesagt ich finde in solchen
krisensituationen
transparenz total wichtig deswegen haben
wir zum beispiel gesagt als die frage
kam könnt ihr uns weitere materialien
die schutzwesten und weiteres liefern zu
sagen wir würden gerne liefern wir
können es nicht weil wir es gerade
selber nicht in den beständen haben und
das was bekannt war wo man leider in den
letzten jahren zu wenig getan hat dass
man gerade bei der beschaffung besser
geworden ist das muss sich jetzt ändern
aber dafür der punkt ist ja wir sind
jetzt vor der situation dass wir manche
dinge nicht haben das heißt wir müssen
sie jetzt schnell kaufen und alles was
wir beitragen können jetzt im rahmen der
nato beitragen und das tun wir auch dass
frau baerbock vor der sie möglicherweise
auch heute abend und in den nächsten
tagen noch stehen nicht zuletzt unter
dem druck der grüne und dabei würde ich
erst mal bleiben sie sind eine
pazifistische orientierte partei hat die
bundesregierung ja daran festgehalten
dem land der ukraine keine waffen zu
liefern nicht einmal defensivwaffen
nicht einmal waffen aus alten ddr
beständen heute wird viel von
solidarität gesprochen mit der ukraine
vom bundeskanzler auch von ihnen ist
hier ein umdenken möglich auch in
richtung lieferung von waffen an die
ukraine auch hier würde ich gerne weil
wir in einer wirklichen krisensituation
sind und dieses format ja schwarz oder
weiß das trifft in solchen situationen
überhaupt nicht zu sondern ist
brandgefährlich weil sie jetzt gesagt
haben pazifistische partei der grünen
wurden wir vor 40 jahren gegründet
deswegen unser klares bekenntnis
mit blick auf das völkerrecht dass wir
militär nutzen um schlimmstes
völkerrechts verbrechen zu verhindern
hat uns herr fischer nutzen 98 auch
gemacht 900 sich im fall kosovo und
serbien ohne un-mandat deutsche flieger
dorthin was tun sie heute für die
ukraine können sie sich vorstellen ein
solches tabu das ist es doch für sie zu
brechen aber darf man mit recht auch
kein tabu aus prinzip sondern wenn man
sagt damit können wir ihr schlimmstes
verhindern oder gute dinge tun wir
erleben gerade dass russland der ukraine
militärisch vollkommen überlegen ist
deswegen sie haben jetzt dinge
angesprochen oder leicht angedeutet mit
blick auf die haubitzen die haubitzen
würden in dieser situation nichts ändern
sie haben selber gesagt aus beständen 30
jahre alt ich habe mir das genau
angeguckt weil ich mir natürlich jeden
punkt in den letzten wochen immer wieder
den kopf zerbrochen haben was können wir
tun aber nicht als selbstzweck damit ich
jetzt hier in ihrer sendung sagen kann
ich als deutscher außenministerin habe
und weiß ganz genau die faktor des 0,0
sicherheit gebracht sondern hätte nur
davon abgelenkt meine zeit für diese
lieferung einzusetzen anstatt meine zeit
darauf zu verwenden was können wir tun
finanzielle mittel bereitzustellen um
hilfe in der ukraine zu leisten diese
hauptsitzen sind 30 jahre alt die können
nicht mal auf dem panzer gebaut werden
deswegen wäre das einfach nur eine farce
gewesen deswegen haben wir gesagt das
ist für uns jetzt nicht der richtige
fokus aber man hat den eindruck dass da
jetzt schon was in bewegung kommt wenn
man so ein paar stimmen auch aus der
sozialdemokratie heute gehört hat etwa
vom spd-chef glauben sie dass das thema
jetzt noch mal kommt und man dann am
ende doch zu einer zu einer position
findet defensivwaffen müssen möglich
sein wenn es jetzt auch zu spät kommt im
grunde für die ukraine
also zum einen die trennung zwischen
defensiv und offensiv waffen führt aus
meiner sicht in die irre deswegen
geräten allgemein über waffen mit waffen
kann man sich verteidigen sie können
auch zum angriff genutzt werden das
haben in anderen situationen gesehen zum
beispiel auch im irak wenn waffen
geliefert werden sagt man die wurden zur
verteidigung genutzt dann wurden städte
eingenommen die waffen waren waren da
wurden von anderen offensiv genutzt
deswegen wir reden über rüstungsexporte
die man immer nur im einzelfall
entscheiden kann und die bundesregierung
die neue bundesregierung wir haben ja
gesagt wir werden das rüstungsexport
kontrollgesetz überprüfen wir werden
weitere verschärfungen einziehen da wo
wir nämlich bisher viele viele fragen
haben warum waffen an regime gehen die
menschenrechte nicht einhalten auf der
anderen seite
auf der anderen seite auf der anderen
seite natürlich macht man politik immer
vor den vor dem hintergrund was in der
realität passiert deswegen wird
natürlich in diesen debatten jetzt genau
diese erfahrung auch mit mit mit
einfließen aber jetzt in diesem moment
müssen wir uns darauf fokussieren das
ist meine verantwortung als deutsche
außenministerin alles dafür zu tun dass
die menschen denen gerade schlimmstes
angetan wird dass wir sie so
unterstützen können dass möglichst
wenige zu schaden kommen fluss auch
meine verantwortung als deutsche
außenministerin die für die sicherheit
der deutschen staatsangehörigen zu
sorgen derzeit sind rund 700 deutsche
staatsangehörige noch in der ukraine wir
wissen nicht ob alle sich in unsere
listen eingetragen haben deswegen möchte
ich hier an dieser stelle auch noch mal
sagen haben die telefon hotline
geschaltet für diejenigen die nach
deutschland kommen wollen an den grenzen
stehen an der grenze stehen der beamte
des auswärtigen amtes die sich dann
natürlich auch auf das haben wir
vorbereitet im europäischen kontakt um
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer kümmern
die jetzt in europa sicherheit suchen
werden sie haben von dialog und härte
gesprochen kann diplomatie jetzt noch
was ausrichten haben sie ganz konkret
mal gefragt noch einen gesprächsfaden
etwa zu ihr kollegen lawrow ja ich habe
am montag mit
herford telefoniert da hat er mich auch
für sichtlich in allen punkten angeloben
weil gesagt wurde nein wir werden hier
nicht weiter eskalieren es hat sich ja
schon abgezeichnet und deswegen auch auf
die frage der vorbereitung wir haben ja
ganz verschiedene szenarien genau uns
angeschaut vorbereitet wir wussten das
ist unterschiedlich angriffe geben
könnte dass dieser worst case szenario
jetzt eintritt das ist einfach furchtbar
so deutlich muss man das sagen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt alles dafür
tun ich komme mit meinem anfangspunkt
zurück aber das sehe ich als unsere
verantwortung als internationale
gemeinschaft russland jetzt ganz klar zu
isolieren und deutlich zu machen das
akzeptieren wir als weltgemeinschaft
nicht grund sollten sie jetzt als
außenministerin mit diesen leuten im
kreml mit putin und labor hat diplomatie
keine chance mehr
der diese bezeichnung bald als liebender
und weil sie gelogen haben also ich
finde man muss dinge auch klar
aussprechen muss jetzt nicht mehr sprich
schönreden aber
diplomatie kann nie zu ende sein weil
dann werden internationale beziehungen
zu ende diplomatie hat offensichtlich in
diesem moment weil wir es mit einem
regime zu tun haben dass sich nicht an
internationale regeln hält nicht
verhindern können dass russland in der
ukraine einmarschiert ist aber wir sind
in einer situation wo es darum geht
menschenleben zu schützen wir sind in
einer situation wo wir offensichtlich im
krieg sind das heißt über über die
fragen ich habe heute in eindringlichen
appell in der osze gehalten dafür da der
nach wie vor einem beobachter mission
der osze der eindringliche appell
deswegen ja ich rede derzeit über
fernseh kameras oder in der osze da
sitzen ja russische vertreter sorgen sie
für die sicherheit der osze
beobachtermission russland hat selber
entsandte dort dorthin geschickt das
heißt natürlich muss man in diesen
formaten
weiterreden um schlimmeres zu verhindern
aber mit der russischen führung so wie
es derzeit ist und sie werden und sie
setzen hoffnungen in die sanktion die
jetzt heute abend wahrscheinlich ja auch
noch von der eu beschlossen werden auch
die usa
beiden wird heute noch etwas ankündigen
reicht das angesichts der vielen
milliarden über die putin durch gas und
öl einnahmen
gefüllte staatsfonds verfügen kann
werden diese sanktionen dann das
stoppschild seien von dem sie sprechen
dass sie sagen bis hier und nicht weiter
haben sie da zu trauen
diese diese sanktionspaket wird
sicherlich nicht dafür führen dass
morgen alle truppen zurückgezogen werden
aber deswegen ist mir so wichtig
deutlich zu machen es geht jetzt in
diesem moment um die ukraine es geht
aber für putin um größeres darüber
hinaus und deswegen sagen wir mit diesem
sanktionspaket so was ist nicht
hinnehmbar das hat konsequenzen und zwar
in den nächsten wochen in den nächsten
monaten werden wir jetzt finanzströme
stoppen dann macht das für morgen und
übermorgen erstmal nichts mehr aus aber
auf dauer muss eine gesellschaft das
tragen können wenn man abgeschnitten ist
vom internationalen finanzmarkt und da
vielleicht auch nur ein wichtiger punkt
was anders ist als 2014 wo ja die
menschen oder viele menschen in der in
russland zu diesem krieg relativ positiv
eingestellt war das ist jetzt anders 70
prozent der bevölkerung russland will
keinen krieg mit der ukraine auch was
ich heute vom botschafter in moskau
gehört habe das ist da sehr sehr viele
kritische stimmen gibt überhaupt nicht
diese
begeisterung was da gemacht wird weil
hier für viele sind das ja freunde
bekannte familie jetzt in der ukraine
direkte angegriffen werden und das
deutlich zu machen auch mit blick auf
die russische gesellschaft die man nicht
gleichsetzen darf mit dem russischen
regime das hat jetzt konsequenzen dass
es für putin auch spürbar ist
wirtschaftlich ökonomisch nicht sofort
das ist es nicht aber das ist ein
bisschen wenn wir jetzt sagen wenn sie
jetzt ihre frage andeutet gar keine
sanktion wäre ja die bringen ja sowieso
nicht wir haben wir sind ein rechtsstaat
zum glück und ihn verteidigen wir
deswegen haben wir in unserer
gesellschaft regeln wenn man regeln
bricht hat das konsequenzen um deutlich
zu machen dass wir akzeptieren das nicht
da weiß man nicht ob derjenige der
straftäter danach nicht eine andere
straftat
begeht sondern nach diese regeln auch
zur bestrafung das tun wir mit diesen
sanktionspaket und wir machen deutlich
dass weitere schritte war ihre massive
konsequenzen hätten wir müssen langsam
zum ende kommen um innenpolitik geht es
ja auch bei uns und es geht auch um die
frage was kann man den bürgern zumuten
man könnte sagen diese tage entscheiden
auch über ihren erfolg über den erfolg
der neuen bundesregierung der ampel
koalition und sie wissen auch ohne
russisches gas können sie ihre
ehrgeizigen klimaziele im grunde nicht
erreichen die energieversorgung
deutschlands zu sichern ist eine ganz
wichtige aufgabe für sie könnte das
heißen wenn es schwierigkeiten gibt mit
den gaslieferungen das wäre die nächste
eskalation aus moskau dann müssten die
grünen bereits sein kohle mehr zu
verbrennen oder atomkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen also erstmal anfang
ihrer frage über die beliebtheitswerte
der deutschen bundesregierung auch der
deutschen außenministerin mache ich mir
gerade überhaupt gar keine gedanken
sondern weil ich aber bewegt hat gemeint
ich habe sie gefragt ob sie auch unserer
bevölkerung etwas zumuten und ob sie
unter diesen bedingungen ihren kurs
fortsetzen kann ja nur zu beginn weil es
ihnen politische auswirkungen hat und
das ist mir wichtig deswegen ich möchte
die haltung dieser bundesregierung und
auch von mir deutlich machen dass wir in
einer situation sind wo man ganz klar
sagen muss auf welcher seite stehen wir
und sich nicht von innen politischen
stimmung weil das haben wir auch erlebt
im zu vorherigen zeiten ablenken lassen
darf das vorweg gesagt deswegen habe ich
heute in meiner ersten erklärung dazu ja
auch sehr deutlich gesagt das wird auch
in deutschland konsequenzen haben das
wird auch einen wirtschaftlichen preis
in deutschland haben die energiepreise
werden steigen herr beck hat ja schon
deutlich gemacht dass sie die versorgung
ist gesichert aber natürlich werden die
energiepreise steigen das war schon so
als ich gesagt hat nur zwei wird
konsequenzen haben wir schon im dezember
dass damit gleich mal die energiepreise
nach oben gegangen sind aber diesen
preis zahlen wir weil wenn wir jetzt die
augen verschließen würden nicht handeln
würden mit sanktionen dann hätte das für
unser verständnis von internationalem
recht einen noch viel höheren preis und
deswegen treffen jetzt alle maßnahmen
und vorbereitung hatten sie angesprochen
mit blick auf gasreserven dass wir dafür
sorgen dass wir gas reserven haben noch
so ein punkt wo wir sagen das ist in der
vergangenheit falsch gelaufen mit blick
auf kohle absicherung wir sind nach wie
vor in der kohleverstromung drin da
müssen wir natürlich jetzt die
vorkehrungen treffen dass wenn kohle
nicht mehr aus russland käme dass wir
sie von anderen ort bekommen und das
macht der wirtschaftsminister gerade
diese vorbereitung entsprechend zu
treffen die regierungen und sie als
außenministerin sind noch keine 100 tage
im abend jetzt konfrontiert mit dieser
situation vor gerade mal einem monat war
antrittsbesuch in moskau zum schluss
dieser sendung wenn sie auf diese
wenigen wochen zurück schauen was was
war die größte erkenntnis im grunde
jetzt und wie bitter ist sie
unglaublich bitter weil ich erlebt habe
das habe ich deswegen auch gesagt wie
einem eiskalt ins gesicht gelogen wird
und zwar nicht nur ich der amerikanische
präsident der französische präsident der
deutsche bundeskanzler
was aber unterstreicht wie wichtig eben
das verständnis einer werte geleiteten
außenpolitik ist die in dieser situation
deutlich macht wir werden unsere werte
im wettstreit darum geht es zwischen
einem autoritären regierung verständnis
und liberalen werten verteidigen das war
was nun vielen dank frau berbalk vielen
dank liebe zuschauern in zuschauer für
ihr interesse übrigens eine sendung nach
zweig plus regeln das muss man in diesen
zeiten auch immer noch sagen hier geht's
jetzt weiter direkt mit dem zdf spezial
um matthias fornoff es aus berlin